In this video, we're going to look at foliage, do a quick take of it, and see what the things
that we can do to build our worlds.
So let's get started.
So foliage is a tool that can help populate our items in our world to get things in the
right spot relatively quickly.
We can get it in there quickly and get the look and visual display that we need, but
is limited when using ray tracing due to photon counts.
Plants, assets with small details are a lot harder on your calculations and noise may
occur, which will force you to use CVARs in some cases.
For the most part, when it comes to ray tracing and foliage, you kind of maybe want to stir
away from that, but if you do have foliage, keep it farther away from the camera.
This will prevent anything in your virtual production from giving you some bad displays.
Now, if you're going for final pixels, you can run some CVARs to get you the best possible
results.
And if your GPU is strong, you should be able to get some good results with it.
But just keep those things in mind.
It's very important to consider.
Ray tracing is evolving and is improving gradually.
And also eventually we'll absorb that, as you can see with our Unreal 5 release, that
Lumens is kind of taking over that particular area and getting stronger and stronger.
So you just need to optimize your scene accordingly if you're to introduce foliage and lots of
small assets if you're working with ray trace.
So if you are having trees move around, make sure you evaluate WPOs, works with your ray
trace foliage.
It's more geared towards final pixels.
In a virtual production environment, ray trace is not really needed all the time, but it
may be.
It just depends on the art director.
They may want to see that bounce immediately.
And that also depends on your hardware and GPU and exactly what you're pushing to be
able to get these results.
And sometimes you could use screen space, global illumination, but you just keep those
things in mind too, because as the camera changes and moves, there may be some clipping
involved.
Hero Static Meshes is ideal to work up close.
So sometimes you may not even need foliage.
You just grab that tree, put it right next to the camera, and that can be a bit more
ideal in many cases.
But let's take a look at foliage up close.
So in my scene, you'll see, and let me get rid of this guy.
He's pretty distracting.
And we'll change our material back to its regular state.
It's going to ask me to save, and I'm going to say no.
Oh, nope.
It decided to stick around.
I might have hit save, and that's fine.
In that case, we'll go in here and lower the strength of it.
A little more gray there.
Kind of closer to what we had before.
Maybe get a little bit wider.
So let's go ahead and take a look at that foliage up close.
Just a little small thing there.
All right.
So we have some plants in here, and I'm going to go ahead and activate my Foliage tool.
In my Foliage tool, Unreal and older versions wouldn't always populate here of what you
had before, but now it does remember what you had, which is fantastic.
And we're going to go ahead and turn all these on for a moment.
Now let's pick on one of them for a second and look at some of our settings.
You'll notice we have some settings here, but there's also some settings up top.
You can also control size, your density, and you can also have some...
You can place it in the current level if you want to, and there's also filter.
So what are you going to paint on?
You want to paint on other foliage on top of foliage, which is...
That's crazy talk.
Your BSPs, which is your generic volume structures.
They can be pieces of geometry for blocking, and Static Mesh and Landscape.
So right now we're going to...
Mainly Static Mesh would be our main point of contact here.
So see we have density.
You can see that my density have increased.
I've also messed with my scale size.
So when I paint, we have a range between a smaller and a bigger size there, and it's
free formed here.
You can keep it uniform if you want to, or lock it within an axis.
That actually can be pretty helpful.
See my brush here?
I'm going to change the scale of that brush by hitting the bracket keys, because I don't
want to paint everywhere.
There we go.
Lower that down, just like with the modeling tool, and I can paint some foliage in place.
Pretty nice.
And I have it so it's creating a really nice density in here.
And we can even edit some of that here as well, some generic sizes.
You can also do selecting of your individual assets by clicking on the Select tab.
It allows you to select these individually.
So you see, oh, you know what?
I don't want this plant here.
You can select it and pick on it if you needed to.
That's up to you.
You can also lasso, which activates your brush tool.
You'll select a certain set that you want to do something with, or you want to change
them in some way.
Or you can even un, you can erase by hitting the Shift key.
It allows you to erase.
But there's also an Erase option up at the top, which is pretty great.
And I'll just erase some more, get rid of some of these.
We don't need all these plants everywhere.
It's crazy talk.
So you have some of these nice selection options and even Fill.
Now you've got to be careful with Fill.
You don't want to initially fill the whole world in the target area because that may
bog things down.
So there is a limit with this.
As amazing as this tool is, it can make your scene come to a crawl.
So you have to use it sparingly and you have to use it wisely.
And that means you know exactly where you're going to put it and how you're going to use it.
Now, if you come into issues in areas where you're like, you know, I think this is great.
But up close, I mean, I've edited some of the plants and I think they're okay.
But up close, I want to be able to have maybe the best, highest quality.
You don't always have to rely on foliage.
You can bring in actual pieces of geometry, just pull them in.
You can bring in the plant on its highest level of detail.
It's up to you how you work that.
But you can do that.
And that's fine too, especially for virtual production.
Because not everything has to be, when it comes to foliage, has to be an actual foliage
item.
If you're up close and looking at something, you may want that tree in its highest level
of detail without, because what happens, it'd be up close to the camera, because what happens
as you load things into foliage, it does become incidents.
There is a little bit of a hit with it, especially on how far you are from the camera.
But you can edit some of this too.
So if I go to this plant that we have active, scroll up, click on the magnifying glass,
I can go into this foliage actor and I can tell exactly how I want to, or how much detail
I want out of this group.
So I can say, hey man, I want high detail.
And when you, or even foliage.
I usually choose high detail when it comes to virtual production because I want to get
the best possible detail.
When you select that, it'll say it's going to change it for all of them.
Are you sure you want to do this?
I'm going to say no in this case.
And it will change it and make it so that you can have the highest amount of detail
for that foliage.
And it can't get expensive if you have a lot everywhere.
So keep in mind too with ray tracing, like I said before, it is expensive and not always
ideal because you want to avoid that noise.
And if you do use it for ray tracing, a lot of times it's better to do that with final
pixel, but you can have some plants and trees in the background.
And a lot of times you're doing a mix of that.
Here's my virtual tree and my virtual production.
Here's my physical tree next to the actor.
So you can actually do a trade off where you have stuff in the distance versus here's an
actual item, a physical prop and get it to match and look like it believes it's believable
for your environment.
So you can do a lot of cheating with that.
So the foliage shul is pretty great in the fact that if you needed stuff and it doesn't
have to be limited to just plants.
Now you can do rocks.
Say we turn all these plants off, even books in a library.
So if I go in here and select these two rocks, like, hey man, I need some rocks.
I can add some rocks in here.
It's really great.
And I can put them on static meshes if I want to.
I may have it deactivated in this particular case for this guy.
You can add it there.
So it's really cool.
It doesn't have to be plants.
It doesn't necessarily have to be trees all the time.
It can just be just some fodder, just some stuff that you have all over the place, stuff
that you just want to populate.
And again, you can control how it looks.
There's a calling distance control too.
Now this is a little bit more gamey and less virtual production.
Specifically for virtual production, a lot of times your camera is pretty fixed.
If it does move, it's very light with its movement.
So some of these you may not even have to worry about, such as collisions and so forth.
I wanted to point that out and show you the strength of what you can do and how you can
control and get your scenes in the right area.